[music playing]
[thud]
[panting]
Ah.
[thud]
[cracking]
[branches crunching]
Excellent work,
[inaudible] Sal.
Come with me.
There are more that need
to be pulled from the sky.
This way.
[birds singing]
I might be of help if you
tell me what you're looking for.
A span of trees.
What sort of trees?
Ones that will hold
and reign over the rest.
This is not that.
Do you agree?
That depends.
Yes.
So much depends.
This is the place.
I'm sure of it.
Do you see how these
create a perfect form?
Yes?
Leave them.
Clear the rest.
What are we building?
A sky table-- these
will be the legs.
Sky table?
Yes.
I wish to stride over the
trees and study the clouds
and the smoke from [inaudible].
No man in New France
will possess such a view.
I have never heard
of such a thing.
I have invented it.
I have made a sketch.
There is no precedent
for such a thing.
[inaudible] at once.
I have been granted a
wife by decree of the king.
And I wish to complete the table
before we are properly bound.
What of Marie?
Marie is not my wife.
Sir.
Worry not, 'tis
the [inaudible]..
Bonjour!
Ah.
Tell me, Sal, what does
a man such as yourself
think of all day, besides
the bite of the axe, I mean?
I think of nothing.
Nonsense.
The bird of thought
enters us all.
What vapors fill your mind?
[sighs] I think sometimes,
uh, of my brother.
He who is dead?
Yes.
This is what
families are like.
The ones who have come
and passed from this world
push us to find new fields.
It is the fear of departing this
realm without leaving a mark.
You must do better
than this dead brother.
You must set a
course for yourself.
I will start with this.
And Marie must not
know a word of this.
Now I need to be
able to trust you.
You have my word.
Good.